the cost of producing cattle right now
is the highest i've ever seen it and it
don't seem to be an end in sight
[Music]
pat dean has been raising cattle his
entire life the third generation rancher
he's used to working seven days a week
365 days a year
we try to get up and get started about
seven o'clock and
we go just as long as we can and to
accomplish as much as we can and
hopefully
nothing out of the ordinary rises we get
to quit at a decent time
sometimes we're out all night over the
years he's seen a lot of ups and downs
but never a crisis quite like this
low prices for our product and high
prices for everything we need to produce
this product but it seems like in the
last year
or two years
all our outgoing money or all our
expenses the things we have to buy just
skyrocketed
american farmers are feeling the pinch
of inflation across entire production
lines the price of fertilizer corn fuel
and labor are up with no ceiling in
sight
we definitely
think
a lot more about purchasing anything
i mean we try to get by
with what we have as best we can and not
buy any new equipment and
try not to do a lot of unnecessary work
as people like pat struggle demand for
beef is spiking
prices were up more than 20 in november
from a year earlier
despite those markups many ranchers say
profits aren't being evenly distributed
there's no guarantee of anything prices
could be
10 cents lower 10 cents higher
just we just we're at the mercy of
the buyers at the sale today
where most people
produce something they kind of control
the price
we don't we just get what we get and
hope it's enough to pay the bills
federal data shows that for every dollar
spent on food the share that went to
ranchers and farmers dropped from 35
cents in the 1970s to 14 cents recently
that could lead to some tough decisions
i hope to be able to do this till i'm
about 65 and and then downsized to just
a few at the house
hopefully we've got enough money to live
on time
by that time but if we don't we can sell
our property and
downsize there too and retire on that
the white house is pointing the finger
at meat packers
since the 1980s the industry has seen
rapid consolidation with only four major
companies dominating the space today
part of that is a movement into bigger
slaughterhouses and bigger meat
processing facilities
that create these economies of scale
that reduce the price of meat but
obviously that creates a capacity
constraint and it's a big capital
investment to create a new one
mike dorning is a washington
correspondent for bloomberg news
overseeing coverage on agriculture he
says that there are a lot of factors at
hand big companies would tell you one of
the problems they face is it's harder
for them to get enough people to work
and keep those factories going
at the kind of pace they want and still
pay the wages that they want
the justice department is investigating
these companies to determine whether
they are violating anti-trust laws the
probe started in the last year of the
trump administration and biden's
administration is pushing forward
earlier this year the government
unveiled one billion dollars in aid for
smaller meat industry producers
so much of the food inflation has been
meat inflation be it beef
pork chicken and that's politically
sensitive not just on the rancher side
but on the consumer side and it
especially hurts middle and low-income
people who use a bigger part of their
budget for food
so the
biden administration has been like
looking for ways to try to attack
inflation while they wait on assistance
farmers are looking for a future that
keeps them on land and following their
passion i hope i'm always able to have a
few just because we enjoy raising them
and that's what we do we just kind of
take it one day at the time and
whatever comes along we'll get through
it one way or the other